a little poison there all right senator
lindsey graham and bernie sanders are
set to face off in a major debate called
the senate project streaming live and
exclusively this monday at noon eastern
on fox nation bret baer will be
moderating the debate and joins us now
to tell us more brett good to see you so
i've done a lot of these debates in
politics what are the rules of the
debate and are these uh politicians
going to be able to dig into the issues
and we can actually see both sides and
have them spar a little bit yeah good
afternoon uh by the way i love intro
intro and they sent a debate with poison
i think that that's really always a good
thing to do
but
lindsey graham and bernie sanders are
poised for this you can't think of two
figures that are ideologically more far
apart as far as where they feel about
different issues and their ability to
articulate it i've dealt with both of
them in many interviews and debate
settings before
but this format is kind of oxford style
it is opening statements and rebuttals
and then there is a q a session with me
as the moderator basically i'm providing
a blueprint and trying to keep them in
the guardrails but the the whole
process here is to try to get
the old way that the senate operated
with
discussion and substance backing up what
you say not just you know tweets against
the wall or sound bites that get picked
up and
i think it's going to be refreshing it's
one hour it's a collaboration with the
bipartisan policy center the edward m
kennedy institute and the orrin hatch
foundation and it's based on the premise
that senator ted kennedy and senator
warren hatch were you know very
different in the way they looked at
politics in the world
but they also came together
to get things done occasionally and
argued about things they disagreed about
yeah really refreshing megan brett
allow me one to apologize for the poison
the chevy vega of american rock
uh and secondly i'm kind of hoping that
bernie sanders and lindsey graham really
hate each other deep down so like is
that some of that bubbles to the surface
there will be some sparring specifically
and you know just just in when you get
into the issues they're so far apart on
some things there will definitely be um
some
you know pointed jabs i'm sure but it's
much more of a discussion and a
conversation and i'm steering it and as
i prepare for this it's uh more about
getting them to engage and less about me
probing them and following up that sort
of thing hey brad i know you have
several of these books we talked about
it on fox and friends weekend i am
curious though how hard it has been to
book these debates there is a little bit
of a sentiment not exclusively but
primarily on the left to not give honor
to your opponent's ideas by confronting
them or debating them have you
encountered that has it been difficult
to book no you know what senator sanders
has always been good and and engaging
and you know
one of the things that senator sanders
supporters will say to you is that he is
who he is he believes who he is and and
stands by what he believes and people on
the other side of the aisle who deal
with senator sanders do say that even
senator graham i talked to him the other
night about it
so
their unique figures
senator sanders is one of them as we go
forward we'll see how you know this
develops i think they're going to be
interesting characters along the way
there's a set of series of three planned
uh we haven't you know kind of unveiled
other things we're going to take part in
this one and hopefully
do more in the future it's going to be
streaming on fox nation live uh we will
put a piece of it on special report and
then there'll be an hour special later
on fox news channel afterwards
all right brett it's it's janine here
the question that i have is last night
obviously you watched the hearing and
i'm just curious as to what you think
the end game is with respect to this
january 6 commission well judge that was
my big question in the post game
analysis on shannon's show about what
where the blueprint that they have where
they're going are they looking for a
criminal charge or are they looking for
trying to prevent former president trump
from running for office again i do agree
with jessica that there were new nuggets
and several of them uh throughout uh
that the committee is going to they say
back up with testimony
benny thompson said afterwards in an
interview that there will be
witness testimony that ties the proud
boys and oath keepers to trump's inner
circle and some communication if that
happens that's that's significant news
in that that regard um i think some of
the things said about you know inner
workings while it was going on are new
um but the biggest question is how can
they keep everything together in seven
committee hearings and where are they
going at the end
well and hey brad um thank you for uh
having me last night and also backing me
up a little there from the e block it
was lonely at this table um i just
wanted to add on to janine's question
and ask you about
the end game but in so far as the
midterms if you think that this will
have any immediate political effect on
what people are going to the polls for
in nepal i mean i think you know the
answer to this i think
that
most people decide first of all we're in
june right we have a long way to go to
november and what is the thing that's
driving most people's angst it's how
you're putting food on the table it's
how you're paying your bills it's the
fact that your check may have gone up
and you're making more money but you're
actually you have less because you're
spending the average according to moody
and moody's analytics is that a family
is paying 460 dollars more per month
than they were for the same amount of
goods and services
460 dollars more per month per family
now that trumps anything else so
is it significant in the big picture it
was a dark dismal day for the country
and on capitol hill and we do need to
remember it and they will
uh but i'm not sure how much it affects
the midterm elections you know brett you
got jessica gloading here when you're on
air because you agree with her uh we're
not going to take offense at the table
of that thank you for joining us we
appreciate it
all right hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now